I realized recently that I didn't really
understand how a Prism Works you see the
standard explanation what you might hear
in a high school physics class for
example goes something like this when
light enters a medium like glass it
slows down if a beam of light enters
this glass at an angle then a
consequence of this slowdown is that it
bends a little bit or using the lingo it
refracts what's going on with a prism
then is that the specific amount that
light slows down depends a little bit on
its
frequency now most of the light that you
see is not a clean pure sine wave in
particular the white light coming from
the sun is not a clean sine wave it's
something much Messier but it can be
expressed as a sum of a bunch of clean
sine waves each one corresponding to a
pure spectral color so when you shine
white light into a prism like this all
those different components get refracted
by slightly different amounts causing
this iconic separation of the pure
rainbow
colors